un dernier sondage du sidaction alerte
sur la banalisation du virus du sida en
particulier auprès des jeunes âgés de 15
à 24 ans 23% des jeunes considèrent
qu'il existe un médicament pour guérir
du sida
ils étaient seulement 13 % en 2009
pourtant quand on pose la question à ces
lycéens dijonnais
la réponse semble évidente on peut pas
malheureusement non là on peut pas mais
enfin il ya des recherches en cours en
tout cas c'est ce que je sais après je
sais que ça avance mais pas
exceptionnellement vit qu'aux autres
points 73 % des jeunes estime que
l'éducation nationale ne les informe pas
assez sur le sujet faut répondre ces
lycéens
ouais moi je trouve qu'on ait informé
comme en bas avec ba au collège et des
cours d'éducation sexuelle
pas beaucoup mais j'en ai eu dans notre
lycée en tout cas on a une journée pour
de prévention pour le sida donc on a des
intervenants qui viennent qui nous
explique un peu plus la maladie
différence entre le sida et le vih et
donc on a vraiment une grande session
sensibilisation en tout cas charles de
gaulle si on n'est pas sûr qu'on n'a pas
fait de test je sais qui il faut mettre
un préservatif alors est-ce une
exception dijonnaise car le sidaction ou
semble alarmiste
ce médecin a son explication ça peut
paraître paradoxal effectivement
l'information est bonne mais les
conduites quelquefois ne sont pas en
accord avec la connexion à la maladie je
pense que le maintenant ça n'apparaît
plus comme une maladie mortelle quoi
heureusement pour les personnes
atteintes mais du coup je pense qu'il ya
des conduites qui sont plus à risque
ce praticien continue donc d'informer
les jeunes des risques en cas de rapport
sexuel non protégé
il peut même désormais leur prescrire
des préservatifs remboursés par
l'assurance maladie